we're exposed to danger Maleficent Ouma
Hades Oh beast him thou we know you were
just trying to protect everyone in
Oregon but you guys seriously messed up
those poor children on the Isle never
did anything to you but they were
punished regardless luckily your son Ben
is a sensible guy and he wanted freedom
for all we're about to list some of the
most surprising moments in d3 but
honestly it's your choice to keep the V
caves locked up that still has us shook
descendants 3 was amazing we got to see
mal and her friends get the happily ever
after they all deserved but there are
some scenes that totally took us by
surprise you're watching the 10 things
nobody saw coming in descendants 3 the
ending ticking down the barrier for good
might seem like a drastic method but in
the end mal chose to live and let live
she realized that you couldn't stop evil
from happening no matter how hard you
tried her decision to take down the
barrier surprised tons of fans we
thought for Nuvi Kay's would win the
chance to attend auradon prep every
single year but instead mal chose to
bring the V case to Oregon all at once
and now I have a whole world but unless
I get that ember it's game over
Hades gives mal the Ember we've now
found out that Audrey had the scepter
she knew that getting her hands on Hades
ember was her only choice with C Leah's
health now snuck into Hades lair and
tried to steal as ember while he was
sleeping
we never once thought that Hades would
simply hand mallas ember but he did just
that mal ended up convincing Hades to
give her the Ember and we were shocked
to see him give it away willingly Malin
umas bond by now we all know that Malin
uma used to be best friends before mal
dumped a bucket of slimy shrimp on her
head we'd have feeling that these 2v
caves would hash things out and become
friends again but we never saw their
special bond coming who else was shocked
in Mallen uma sword collided and over
Audrey's evil spell their special bond
remains an unsolved mystery J&L hit it
off
who minor pirates love getting into
trouble but they chose to help mal and
her friends save auradon from Audrey's
evil reign now Carlos and Jey had their
reservations about Booma Harry and Gil
but with Evie's help they started to
break the ice we could try to be friends
put our history behind us and celebrate
our differences
Jane Gil totally hit it off to our great
surprise their instant bond was enough
to make Harry and Carlos jealous who
knew that these two would become fast
best friends berry the flirt where are
we the only ones who thought that uma
and Harry were endgame
probably not we mean these two were all
over each other in descendants - we were
under the impression that uma and Harry
would start dating in the three quilled
but that's not how the cookie crumbled
[Music]
Harry was flirting with everyone
throughout the film and it caught us by
surprise Harry and Audrey Harry and
Audrey are from two different worlds
Audrey's a classy princess who cares
about appearances and titles and here
he's a reckless pirate who loves
adventure and stolen treasure yet
somehow sparks flew between these two at
the end of the movie it looks like
audrey has finally given up on Ben and
decided to take a walk on the wild side
she knows that here is not a prince
right see Leah's decision Disney
descendants released a few trailers that
made us think that Celia was rotten to
the core but that was far from the truth
she helped mal get the ember and risked
her life to save everyone in auradon
but when she found out that mal was
lying to her she acted quickly she
grabbed the Ember out of mouse hand and
threw it into the well we were shocked
by her actions but then again Celia just
wanted to see her father again
knows the truth most of the vks were
raised by single parents and they have
no idea who they're missing parent is
this was the case for mal or so we
thought we were totally stunned when mal
came face-to-face with Hades and
flat-out called him dad what was even
more shocking was that Hades knew that
mal was his daughter to Hades comes
through Hades is the god of the
underworld and he loves his job he would
do anything to escape the Isle and take
back what's his
so when mal asks Hades to come to Oregon
and save Audrey's life we were sort of
shocked when he said yes
the Oregon guards put Hades in Chains
and treated him like a prisoner but
Hades managed to keep his cool
he used his Ember to wake Audrey up and
then chose to return to the Isle
peacefully we were surprised that he
went back to the Isle despite having the
perfect chance to escape
he could have saved Audrey and then hit
the road but he stuck around to prove
that he was good
now suggests to shut down the barrier
for good now EB Carlos and Jane know
what it's like to grow up poor and
lonely on the Isle
they represent the decays and would do
anything to help them out or so we were
led to believe now caught us by surprise
when she suggested that they close down
the barrier for good I think that we
have to close the barrier forever
Belem beasts were obviously on board but
then was just as shocked as we were what
surprised you the most about descendants
3 tell us in the comments thanks for
watching like this video and subscribe
to our channel if you haven't already
and be sure to hit that notification
bouncing you never miss another video
we'll see you next time
[Music]